thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
about smile from me smile want me to
help you least you could do is give me a
smile crucially he makes contact with
the map that Captain Marvel is holding
pulls it down and says something that
might be interpreted as a threat how
about a smile for me this guy is not a
particularly nice guy
and crucially here he has invaded
captain Marvel's space
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and I really mean that this
time because there are a lot of people
engaging in quasi legal analysis and
really messing it up would you believe
that the men who are complaining about
Captain Marvel again are wrong about the
law I know it's crazy but stick with me
here by the way since we're dealing with
a Marvel property as always there will
be a post credit scene at the end of
this video so a little background about
Captain Marvel before we dive into the
current ridiculous controversy that is
surrounding this franchise
Captain Marvel came out last summer it
had slightly more controversy than
normal because as far as I can tell and
I wasn't following this closely the lead
superhero is a woman and the lead
actress brie Larson said some semi
controversial things about racism and
sexism in Hollywood I do not need a
40-year old white dude to tell me what
didn't work for him about a wrinkle in
time I don't eat white dudes I'm just
saying we need to be conscious of our
bias and do our part to make sure that
everyone is in the room that led some
people predominantly men to boycott the
film which appears to have had no real
effect because the movie did fine when
it came out last summer fast forward to
last week when the producers of the
movie released a deleted scene where
Captain Marvel more or less beats up a
guy on a motorcycle this led to a
reaction on certain parts of the
internet some called Captain Marvel a
villain I just see a villain I see
Captain Marvel written
as a villain here the scenes awful
portrays Carol as a villain that's why
they cut it Carol Danvers is supposed to
be the charismatic endearing and
likeable heroine of the film but she
behaves here like you'd expect a villain
to behave
apparently feminists believe that women
encounter guys like this all the time
and it's such a hardship an even
conservative commentator ben shapiro
gave this theory a signal boost does she
actually think that alienating people
like me is going to be big box office of
course not she knows that she's not
completely dumb is that like a personal
attack or something the argument as far
as I can tell is as follows the deleted
scene shows that a man on a motorcycle
is rude to Captain Marvel in a totally
unprovoked attack Captain Marvel
effectively beats the hell out of the
guy and steals his motorcycle instead of
using her words Captain Marvel engages
in violence and is therefore the villain
the problem with this argument is that
it is legally and morally incorrect I
don't begrudge these commentators too
much it's a clever attempt at being
contrarian it's just that the evidence
doesn't really support this argument and
the attempts to shoehorn this movie and
in particular this deleted scene into a
particular conservative narrative just
doesn't really work
now I'll note on the side that I'm not
in a habit of commenting on this kind of
popular minutia but it just so happens
that I was in the process of writing a
practice exam for law students a law
school hypothetical that involved a very
similar fact pattern to what is
portrayed in the deleted scenes and as a
second decide I'm going to go through
this clip in what some might consider
excruciating detail because that's what
you do in law school legal analysis is
mostly factual analysis and so since
this particular fact pattern was so
close to what I was already working on I
thought it would be a great opportunity
to talk about some of the legal analysis
that law students and lawyers go through
on an everyday basis but let's examine
the clip all right clearly a Los Angeles
strip mall I would recognize that
architecture or lack thereof anywhere
nice scuba suit you need a rad darling
okay so clearly here Captain Marvel
Carol Danvers is reading a map or a
newspaper she's minding her own business
and some guy on a motorcycle has parked
his motorcycle at the strip mall and he
has made an unwanted overture not the
most polite thing to do but not illegal
either and of course I guess I have to
point out that Captain Marvel is fully
within her rights to completely ignore
this gentleman and not engage with him
in any way shape or form that is also
perfectly legal about smile for me huh
smile yeah I'm gonna help you at least
you could do is give me a smile okay
this is the crucial act that takes place
that really changes the narrative
entirely the man on the motorcycle has
parked his motorcycle he's taken his
helmet off he stood up he walked over to
Captain Marvel he put his hand on the
map that she was holding and is clearly
right next to her you can see that his
arm is sort of angled which means that
the distance between Captain Marvel and
himself must be just a matter of inches
because it's not like he was reaching
out with his hand in an extended fashion
he's reaching out his hand in a way that
makes it seem like the map is directly
in front of him and crucially he makes
contact with the map that Captain Marvel
is holding pulls it down and says
something that might be interpreted as a
threat how about a smile for me this guy
is not a particularly nice guy and
crucially here he has invaded Captain
Marvel's space this is a crucial
distinction that we'll talk about in
just a second because in my opinion I
think that that meets the statutory
definition of assault and battery I'm
offering to help you at least you could
do is give me a smile
so his hand has left the map he is still
standing very close to her but it
appears that his arms are at his side
and Captain Marvel has taken the map put
it to the side and she's about to
confront this man how about a handshake
I'm dears
people call me the dawn Wow all right so
they both engage in what could be
considered a consensual handshake at
which point Captain Marvel then begins
to squeeze and I guess electrocute this
guy I actually didn't see the movie so I
don't know exactly what her powers are
but he's clearly in pain as a result of
this grip that Captain Marvel has put on
in this handshake here's a proposition
for you you're gonna give me your jacket
your helmet your motorcycle and in
return I'm gonna let you keep your hand
okay so why do I think that this may
qualify as assault and battery well
battery is a criminal offense involving
the unlawful physical contact or
touching of another person which is
either considered harmful or offensive
and battery is distinct from the
separate crime of assault which is the
act of creating the apprehension of
contact or unlawful touching there are
two flavors of battery in most
jurisdictions there is the crime of
battery which is prosecuted by the state
and then there's also the tort of
battery which is what you would accuse
someone of if you wanted to sue them for
civil damages in a lawsuit but most of
this discussion should apply to both
by way of example California Penal Code
section 242 defines battery as any
willful and unlawful use of force or
violence upon the person of another to
meet this criteria the prosecutor has to
be able to prove that the defendant
intentionally and unlawfully touched
another person in a harmful or offensive
manner and the second element which is
that the defendant did not act in
self-defense
or in the dens of someone else as any
law student will tell you even the
slightest touch can be enough to satisfy
the battery statute if it's done without
consent or in a harmful or offensive way
in fact you learn very early on in law
school about the so called eggshell
skull theory which is that if you make
contact with someone who has a skull
that is as thin as an eggshell you're
liable for those damages even if the
kind of touching that you do would not
even hurt another person but if it's
enough to hurt someone with a very
unusual condition what we call the
eggshell skull I don't actually know if
that is an actual medical condition or
not that's enough to make you on the
hook for the damages that you caused as
a result of your unconsented to touching
or battery in this case and almost as
important is that the contact
requirement with another person is
satisfied even if it's just touching
their clothing or if you touch something
that is immediately connected to that
person so if you punched someone and you
punch them through their shirt now
technically you haven't made contact
with that person but because the shirt
is so connected to the person punching
them through a garment of some kind is
enough to satisfy the touching of a
person requirement and crucially that
extends to things that are immediately
connected outside of the clothing as
well so for example if someone was
walking down the street and they were
holding a cell phone in their hand if
you went up to that person and smacked
the cell phone right out of their hand
well even if you don't actually make
contact with the person's hand or their
forearm the fact that they were holding
the cell phone and fell out of their
hand that's enough to qualify as battery
for the person and if the victim saw you
coming and was an apprehension of that
contact then you'd also be guilty of the
crime and tort of assault as well that's
the apprehension of the physical contact
so not only would that count as
destruction of property
it would also qualify as potentially the
crime of assault and battery we see that
in the clip the man on the motorcycle
invades captain Marvel's physical space
there was no reason for him to
stand-up from his motorcycle and walk
the 10 to 15 feet away from the
motorcycle into captain Marvel's
physical space there was no reason for
him to place his hands on the map or the
newspaper the Captain Marvel had in her
hands now of course no one's going to
argue the Captain Marvel was physically
harmed by this interaction but that's
not a requirement to the crime of
battery all that is required is the
touching of something that is
immediately connected to Captain Marvel
and I think that makes the statutory
definition of assault and the fact that
he has invaded her personal space that
he's standing only inches away from her
saying something that could arguably
constitute a threat against her I think
that qualifies as assault as well so
this guy's actions I think constitute
the harmful or offensive touching of
Captain Marvel she is effectively the
victim of being battered by this guy on
the motorcycle and the thing about being
a victim of effectively battery and the
apprehension of battery assault that
gives you access to the legal
justification of self-defense arguably
she was partially justified here now
those are of course the legal arguments
but even if we're gonna talk about
philosophy
I think morally speaking it's the
motorcycle guy who initiates force and
under almost any conception of morality
once someone has initiated force against
you you are privileged enough to use the
defense of force against that person so
long as you don't escalate from using
normal force into using deadly force
which it doesn't appear that Captain
Marvel did here was Captain Marvel
justified in taking this it's motorcycle
and jacket no probably not
but mr. at motorcycle rider committed
battery in the first place and deserves
some of what came to him and we can
argue about how much force was justified
and what kind of apprehension Captain
Marvel was in and what kind of fears she
faced from the sky but certainly it is
not as clear-cut as Captain Marvel is
the villain or the motorcycle guy was
completely innocent it's never black and
white the legal reality is always gray
my guess is that some but not all
the force was justified at the end of
the day this tempest in a teapot was
really about a select few people who
wanted to have a very idiosyncratic view
of this deleted scene and really all of
those man's planners who wanted to make
a clever point about Captain Marvel
being the villain ended up becoming the
thing that they hate most in this world
they are wrong on the Internet and as an
aside everyone recognizes that this
scene is basically an homage to what
happens in Terminator 2 right this scene
is shot for shot exactly what happens to
Arnold Schwarzenegger in t2 I need your
clothes your boots and your motorcycle
no one called Arnold Schwarzenegger a
villain in the scene everybody knows
he's the hero I mean obviously he was
the villain in Terminator 1 but he's the
good guy in Terminator 2 and this scene
from Captain Marvel is basically exactly
the same scene over again but I guess
it's different if the superhero has a
vagina now that mr. motorcycle douchebag
lost his jacket and helmet he could
really use a whole wardrobe makeover
black leather is so 5 years ago he could
really use a slim cut fully custom suit
from Indo Chino which he could even wear
to his arraignment for battering Carol
Danvers all of my suits are now custom
made by indogene Oh including this
three-piece suit that I'm wearing right
now with a custom double-breasted vest
which i think is awesome I love Indo
Chino suits and I buy them with my own
money I love them so much that I
personally reached out to them and I'm
thrilled that they're now a sponsor of
this channel see the secret to a great
suit is all about the fit I'm a
reasonably athletic guy and I can never
buy suits off the rack because they just
simply never fit right indochina will
make you a fully custom suit tailored
specifically for you for less than $400
and the best part is they still use the
best materials like super 140 wool and
cashmere I will never get an
off-the-rack suit again you have tons of
choices too you can send your
measurements in online or you can go to
a physical store and have a stylist take
your own measure
which is what I did when my buddy Andrew
took all of my measurements for over 90
minutes when I went in for the first
time Andrew took my measurements and a
couple weeks later I got the best
fitting suit of my entire life it was
perfect right out of the box legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379 when you enter the
code legal eagle at checkout or use the
link in the description
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel that's Indo Chino com promo
code legal eagle for the best custom
suit of your entire life Captain Marvel
is not a villain because she beats up on
a guy who battered her but she is a
villain because she didn't put the
friggin Infinity Gauntlet on she had it
in her hand she was carrying it like a
football why didn't you just put the
gauntlet on Carol just snap your fingers